this morning the government releases its
jobs report for may amid
expectations of a rebound after a week
showing in april
there is concern about persistent
unemployment in some states including
california
which has the largest economy of them
all our lead national correspondent
that's david begna is in los angeles now
with more on the story
david good morning to you good morning
to you it's kind of a
tale of two realities here in california
on one hand you have the projections for
a
booming economy once the state fully
reopens later this month
and there are signs of that that we're
seeing now but on the other hand you
have tens of
thousands of people looking to find work
or get their old
job back and a lot of them really can't
afford to wait much longer
business is back here at gasolina cafe
in los angeles meatballs ready that's
the owner and chef sandra cordero
who just bought some new tables for her
growing crowds
the restaurant was hit hard by the
pandemic we pivoted
i don't know 10 times we you know went
from takeout to doing take
out dinners we started cooking meals for
healthcare workers
we you know for me it was really
important to keep my core staff employed
she is now ready to ride an economic
upswing
this is an opportunity for the entire
state just yesterday governor gavin
newsom announced more help for
california businesses
he gave the green light for restaurants
to expand outdoor seating
and to serve alcoholic drinks to go i
think this is a good thing for our
economic recovery this pandemic's not
behind us
this pandemic is not extinguished we saw
an enormous amount of work to do
and that work includes solutions for the
unemployed
california has a higher unemployment
rate than the national average
in april it remained over eight percent
and the tourism and hospitality industry
a multi-billion dollar moneymaker before
the pandemic
is one of the last to recover when you
lose your job i think you lose
your a little bit your dignity too take
frank santos
he worked for eight years as a chef at
terranea resort
he got laid off last march because of
the pandemic and he had to move in with
his daughter
while collecting unemployment you have
to
live basically from charity you know
that's what
unemployment is for me you know is
charity
and i just need my job back rosalia
rodriguez needs to get her job back too
she's a hotel room inspector she's a
single mom who's now taking care of a
granddaughter
not knowing how much longer her
unemployment benefits are going to last
we want to go back to work we don't want
to be collecting unemployment we want to
go back to work as soon as possible
i hear you loud and clear if they call
me tomorrow i'll be there tomorrow
you'll be there
both rosalia and frank are hopeful they
will get that call back to work pretty
soon
you know there's a california law passed
in april that requires certain employers
to hire the people they laid off during
the pandemic before they hire new
workers
that means even though their industries
are somewhat slower to recover people
like frank and rosalia
should be the first in line when the
phone call comes to go back
hope to see that soon david thank you